the 2014 but we have special guests in
our studio that's right we have two
special guests we've got Bal Herndon and
Archer noise of the young professionals
board here at the st. Louis jazz club
yes the young professionals board a very
important new innovation not so new
anymore I think it's been around a
little while but the point being to get
professionals involved in helping the
club get a better outreach for chess in
the area and beyond welcome to the show
guys I'm glad to see you again
we we know each other for different
reasons but first I'll let you start
boat why did you get involved on the
young professionals board yeah when I
was first invited onto the board
I was actual bit hesitant to be honest
because I'm not a great chess player but
you know when I heard a lot about what
the scholastic chess initiative is doing
and how it's in the past ten years it's
impacted 55,000 students you know
working with young people mentoring
young people is something a very
passionate about something to do with
technology currently they're teaching a
coding class as well and so I saw this
is one more way to get involved and
really help that and you know spread the
good word of another good thing that's
happening in the city great and audre
you and I work together to take them
down we have that fashion show pinned
and we work to create a chess uniform
together how's everything going in the
fashion world by the way it's going good
we're gearing up for Fashion Week at the
beginning of September so entering into
a busy few weeks but it's been good yeah
Penn certainly made a splash that dress
where is it that dress we designed and
we won by the way ahead of Jennifer and
all the also-rans Christian and their
teams it's it's currently on display in
my studio you know it's it's tucked away
very very safely but yes since then
we've been continuing to grow our
business and the operations here in st.
Louis
continuing our sales kind of nationally
we recently distressed Alex Morgan the
World Cup soccer star and that was
pretty exciting and since then I've done
six collections if you can believe it
I didn't collaborate with me again I
know what I'm yeah
you know the winning squad here all
right I'm gonna let you guys you get
away with that one bow technology and
chess what's the connection that's a
good question so with with chess I think
and similar to technology there's a lot
of strategies and best practices a
course you can implement they'll help
you with success but at the end of the
day you gotta be creative if you got to
be responsive to change and use that
creative problem-solving if you're gonna
be successful I also understand it's
good to know the player playing against
can be helpful in the game of chess well
it's very important technology as well
you got to know who you're designing for
the humans involved in that system
that's one thing that we prioritize a
lot in technology and I think that's
that's one obvious connection that can
make absolutely and what about this
question for you our draw fashion and
chess
what's that connect well you can see my
outfit today I chose black and white you
know for me personally and my in my
designs there's a constant tension
between structured clean tailoring and
then fluidity and I see that in the game
you know these clean lines these set
you know set motions but you also have
to be on your toes and be fluid and
agile and so that you see directly in my
in my garments and toes and I think in
general chess is served as an
inspiration for fashion shows and
editorials I'm really excited about the
beautiful game opening in October where
I'm actually gonna have a piece on
display as well so you'll be able to see
my direct inspiration there love the
love that answer very clean smooth
efficient indeed helping out kids with
the young professionals board as a
mission I'll let you two speak to it
first you bow what what touches you
about I think that whenever I mean chess
is just was one meeting to do that right
one platform and so a lot of the skills
that you learn through teaching the game
apply to a much much more beyond just
chess itself right the grit the
perseverance the creative
problem-solving as I mentioned in other
capacity I think it's all things the
kids are going to take away from it and
you know of course I learned moves to
learn how to become better chess players
but then I think taking those traits and
those characteristics that can apply in
a very positive way to their life in the
long term I think that's awesome
indeed in you Audrey I might personally
got involved because upon moving here I
loved that the chess campus was an
advocate for the Arts with the music
theory
the exhibition's are obviously pin
that's something I wanted to support
with my with my you know personal
efforts in time but I think I'm really
excited to further the network of young
professionals around the Tres campus
working with other boards across st.
Louis as well to just to build that
community build that that advocacy here
well we appreciate all the work that you
guys do
we're bo Herndon and Audra noise working
with the young professionals board to
help build the magic that is chess here
in st. Louis always great to have extra
great people on our side thanks